Salut à vous, peuple des internet. C'est assez drôle parce que je suis en train de finir cette vidéo et le montage très très tard
et je dois rajouter ça avant, alors que la vidéo qui va suivre a été tournée à 8H du matin !
C'est beaucoup trop tôt...!
J'ai rencontré au mois de mai lors d'une émission de radio le champion de france de mémoire et je l'ai invité sur la chaîne pour voir
les techniques qu'il utilise et faire le cobaye.
On avait pris comme thème les pays les capitales qui sont des choses qui servent toute la vie forcément.
Et juste avant de commencer une petite annonce très rapide: il y a quelques jours est sorti notre jeu avec Céline H. qui s'appelle "Menteur Menteur".
C'est un jeu qui est basé sur le bluff mais ça vous en saurez plus ce vendredi puisque on s'est fait une petite
partie des familles avec Max Bird, Lola Dubini, Doc Seven etc, mais là c'est surtout pour vous dire que depuis dix jours
j'ai lancé une boutique en ligne sur:
www.fabienolicard.com
où vous pouvez retrouver mon livre c'est possible aussi de le dédicacer, il y a aussi les livres des copains du Tattoo de Doc Seven de
Max Bird, il y a aussi mon jeu il y a aussi
le tee-shirt que j'ai créé qui permet de mentaliser des gens, il y a des places de spectacle pour l'Olympia, on est à
presque 25 % je crois de remplissage. C'est ouf ! C'est génial !
Je suis très très touché que vous réserviez si longtemps à l'avance.
Et les bonnes places commencent vraiment à être prises c'est cool
si vous ne l'avez pas fait, réservez. Il y a un lien dans la description.
Bon, c'est pas juste pour vous parler de la boutique comme ça c'est surtout que j'ai créé des packs qui sont
valables jusqu'à Noël ou par exemple si tu prends le t-shirt plus le jeu ou
ou le jeu plus le livre par exemple
enfin des packs comme ça,
où quand tu prends plusieurs choses ça fait 15 % de réduction par rapport au prix de vente normal et petit bonus pour la fin
il y a un cadeau avec chaque commande et dans les packs il y a deux cadeaux et dans les grands packs il y a trois cadeaux. C'est sur www.fabienolicard.com
Je vous mets le lien dans la descrisption, vous checkez si vous avez envie et sinon bonne vidéo et ça fait plaisir ! Ciao !
Salut ! Bonjour !
Comment allez vous ? Moi ça va merci de m'avoir posé la question. Il y a quelque chose que j'ai jamais fait l'effort de faire c'est d'apprendre
les capitales et les pays. Je vais plutôt faire appel à un pote qui est juste champion de France de mémoire.
Monsieur Sébastien Martinez !
Donc ça fait quelques temps qu'on se connaît. Comment on s'est rencontré ? Ah ! On s'est rencontré à la radio, en duplex.
-Moi j'étais à Aix.
-Et moi j'étais à Paris.
-C'est ça. France inter ou un truc comme ça ?
-Oui, je crois oui.
-On m'a rappelé le lendemain pour refaire un duplex, et tu étais encore en plein dans ta tournée.
Il doit se dire "Mais si qui ce relou qui vient toujours en même temps !"
-Et moi je me disais à peu près la même chose.
Alors en plus de ça, l'avantage c'est que je les connais vraiment pas mes capitales je n'ai jamais fait cet effort là.
Donc je vais les apprendre en même temps que vous et
si vous avez des questions vous me les dites dans les commentaires et je le répèterai.
Ne faites pas ça parce que c'est pas en même temps !
Arrête de croire tout ce que tu vois sur YouTube !
-Tu vois dans un premier temps quand on fait cet exercice, il faut se tester, il faut vérifier ce qu'on connait déjà parce que ça n'a pas de sens de réapprendre ce qu'on connaît déjà
ça c'est un peu la limite toujours avec les stratégies de mémorisation.
Faisons d'abord une photo parce qu'il
y a déjà plein de choses que l'on connait. Donc on se teste comme ça et une fois qu'on
s'est testé après on prend que les capitales qu'on ne connait pas.
Dans la liste on commence par...l'Autriche.
-Autriche, ça me va.
-Alors le principe pour pouvoir mémoriser, tu l'expliques tout le temps, c'est de créer du lien.
De créér du lien avec ce que tu maîtrises déjà donc là on va jouer avec tes associations et bien sûr chaque
chaque personne va peut-être avoir des associations différentes. A "Autriche" tu penses à quoi ?
Je pense à une autruche parce que autant je ne connais pas sa capitale autant je connais sa forme
parce que j'ai tout un système que tu dois avoir aussi pour
pour connaître la forme des pays.
-Oui c'est ça. Donc une autruche.
-Une autruche.
-Très bien. Et donc la capitale après on a Viennes.
Viennes qu'est-ce que ça t'inspires ?
-Ca m'inspire de l'eau.
-De l'eau ?!
-Déjà. Heu...
-Ok. Et pourquoi de l'eau d'ailleurs ?
-Parce que j'ai longtemps confondu Viennes et Venise.
-Ok ! Super.
-Voilà c'est pour ça.
-Génial.
De l'eau? Donc tu vois de l'eau comme ça ?
-Donc je vois de l'eau, je vois des maison dans l'eau etc. En fait moi je vois Venise quand je pense à Viennes.
-Génial. On va jouer avec ça alors.
Imagine donc de l'eau, ça va être Venise, donc Viennes, et maintenant une fois qu'on a deux associations donc deux associations qui te sont propres
tu créér une histoire, une connexion donc une autruche et venise qu'est-ce qu'on peut...?
-Moi j'ai une autruche qui court tellement vite, qu'elle ne s'enfonce pas dans l'eau. Elle peut courir sur l'eau mon pote.
-Ah oui donc elle court et là il y a tous les bâtiments qui la regarde, on est sur Venise c'est ça ?
-Oui.
-Et elle court, court, court, ok super.
-Et en plus de ça, ça lui permet de venir jusqu'à moi l'autruche.
-Voilà donc parfait, on a un lien.
Maintenant on a la Bulgarie. Tu connais ?
-Bulgarie, non.
-Très bien, donc Bulgarie ça t'inspire quoi ?
-Heu... Bulgarie, Bulgarie... "Bulgar" ça me fait penser à "cigare".
-Cigare ok.
Souvent il y en a qui me parlent des yaourts.
-Ah ! Alors pas du tout !
-Il y en a qui pensent à ça.
-Ce n'est pas naturel pour moi, mais ouais peut-être pour vous ouais.
-Donc toi tu m'as dit un cigare.
-Ouais.
-Super. Donc c'est Sofia la capitale. Qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire le mot Sofia ?
Que tu as entendu... par exemple les malheurs de Sophie, que tu as déjà vu...Est-ce qu'il y a une personne...
-Non, moi ça me ferai plus penser à un sofa dans ce cas.
-Un sofa parfait.
Il y en a qui me disent qu'ils connaissent une Sophie.
-Peut-être qu'il y a une Sophie qui nous regarde !
Envoies moi une photo qu'on puisse associer ton image.
-Ecoute, moi je vais mettre une Sophie virtuelle sur un Sofa.
En train de fumer un cigare et ça fait des bulles.
Comme ça je suis sûr... [rires]
-Donc t'imagines ce gros cigare, quel goût ce cigare ? T'imagines un goût particulier ?
-Bubble gum justement.
-Bubble gum. C'est ça, alors ça j'insiste sur les sens, parce que le plus important c'est d'utiliser au maximum nos 5 sens.
-Ouais.
-On parle de synesthésie quand on a une information visuelle qui nous arrive, on a une aire cérébrale qui est sollicitée.
Quand c'est auditif c'est une autre aire.
En fait chaque sens est connectée à une aire.
Et donc facilement on peut imaginer que si on utilise les 5 sens, la synesthésie, on va plus facilement derrière, récuperer la donnée.
Chypre, tu connais Chypre ?
-Non !
-Très bien, donc Chypre tu penses à ?
-A des chips.
-Nicosie, la capitale.
-Ben, Nicolas.
C'est Nicolas moi.
-Nicolas. Tu as un Nicolas dans ta vie ?
-J'ai un Nicolas écoutes, je vais vous dire l'ancien président ça me va très bien. [imitation Sarkozy]
-Nikel, l'ancien président. Donc chips l'ancien président Nicolas.
-Parce qu'en plus Nicolas Sarkozy, ça fait Nicosie.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est parfait.
-Qui se gave de chips.
-Ah ouais sans problème.
-Frénétique, tu vois il est miam miam miam...
-Ah ouais. Il n'y a pas de souci.
-Quel goût elles ont ces chips ?
-Heu... le goût de l'amertume.
[rires]
-Ok donc on a Chypre. On continue.
On a après... Danemark.
Ca t'inspire quoi ?
-Danemark, ça me fait penser à des kiwis.
-Des kiwis ?
-Ouais, à cause d'un vieux forçage psychologique qui fait passer par Danemark et finir par kiwi, éléphant, etc, etc...
-Ok, ok, effectivement.
-Copenhague, copenhague...
-Donc si tu n'as rien qui vient spontanément, je pense que c'est parce que tu n'as pas de lien de logique.
-Non, non, je n'ai aucun lien logique.
-Donc il faut se focaliser sur la sonorité.
-Tu veux que je te donne l'association que j'ai ?
-Ouais.
-Moi c'est une coupe avec des algues dedans.
-D'accord.
-Coupe/algue.
-Alors moi j'étais plus parti sur un flic...
-Un flic ?
Ah oui "a cop" ok.
-Sur une vague. Un flic américain sur une vague.
-Ah ouais il surf un peu ?
-Ouais exactement.
[rires]
-Du coup il va jongler en même temps.
-Il jongle avec des kiwis...
-Ah ça va être hyper compliqué ! Mais il peut le faire !
Mais bien sûr !
-Et donc même, une fois qu'il se gamelle comme ça,  il tombe dans l'eau.
-Exactement.
-Plus c'est marrant mieux ça fonctionne.
-Ca me va.
Les pays baltes, Estonie.
Estonie, le tigre est en toi !
Ami né en 1980, toi même tu sais !
Donc Estonie, Tallinn, qu'est-ce que ça t'inspires ?
-C'est quoi la ville ?
-Tallinn.
-Tallinn, d'accord.
-Qu'est-ce que ça... Ah c'est marqué là.
-Ouais mais je ne regarde pas trop t'as vu.
Tallinn, Tallinn... Moi je changerai une lettre pour faire tajine.
-Parfait !
-Mais il faut juste que j'intègre ce changement, cette lettre en plus.
-Estonie donc ton tigre...
-Ouais, exact.
C'est pas dur, il essaye de l'attraper pour la manger.
-Ah oui ! Parce qu'elle vole ! Ah oui oui !
-Et elle se moque de lui en plus, c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il se met à l'attraper, elle décolle un petit peu.
-Ah oui c'est bon ça, j'image ouais.
-On se teste ? Ca me paraît pas mal. Parce que l'importance aussi c'est que vous compreniez bien la mécanique que nous amène Sébastien.
-C'est ça, et de toute façon, ça fait parti de la mécanique. Une fois qu'on a terminé ces associations, il faut,
en général c'est ce que je fais au bout de 5 ou 10, en fonction de la vitesse.
-Ouais.
-On se reteste pour vérifier, pour bien ancrer.
-Oui pour voir ce qui est bien encrer, bien sûr.
-Alors Chypre, ce sont les chips de Nicolas Sarkozy.
A savoir Nicosie.
-Nicosie ! Super.
-Tout à fait.
Tu savais que celle-ci je ne la connaissais vraiment pas, il n'y a pas de...
-Bulgarie ?
-Bulgarie,  alors c'était plus dur, mais du coup je suis sur mon sofa, en train de fumer des cigares bubble gum qui font des bulles, avec Sophie, Sofia.
-Autriche ?
-L'autriche, bon bah là j'ai mon autruche qui vient vers moi dans Venise donc Viennes.
Estonie, avec ma petite tajine qui s'envole et qu'il n'arrive pas à avoir, mais elle s'envole parce qu'elle a des ailes.
Donc c'est Tallinn.
Et le Danemark, alors tu vois ça c'est les kiwis...
Alors heureusement que j'ai gardé le kiwi. Alors d'où l'importance de bien se faire confiance sur sa première image,
parce que Danemark ça ne me disait rien du tout, mais à part kiwi... Ah oui donc c'est kiwi en fait !
-Et ça vu de l'extérieur, tu te dis mais qu'est-ce qu'il raconte quoi ?!
-Ouais, c'est ça ouais.
-Mais tant mieux en fait, si vu de l'extérieur c'est "Mais qu'est-ce qu'il raconte ?",
c'est que c'est la bonne association.
-Ouais.
-Parce que souvent c'est très spontané.
Plus ce sera spontané mieux c'est.
-J'aurai pris la danette pour le coup, les trucs comme ça, j'aurai pas trouvé.
Et donc j'ai mon flic sur la vague, Copenhague.
-Ok, parfait !
-Ouais, ouais, oui oui !!!
-Yes, on peut t'applaudir !
-Et je pense peut-être que vous aussi vous l'avez fait en même temps.
Donc là on a fait l'exemple pour 5, on a vraiment pris le temps.
Mais je pense que vous avez bien compris ce qu'à amené Sébastien là dessus.
Quelle rythme toi après de révision pour ce genre de chose, tu leur conseilles ?
Ce qui faut c'est au début le faire souvent.
-Ouais.
-Donc là même dès qu'on a fini le refaire. Dans la journée, le refaire quasiment 2 fois, de suite après, et ensuite le soir ou avant de se coucher.
-Dans la semaine, le faire une fois, et après de toute façon si on apprend des informations comme ça qui sont cohérentes dans la vie de tous les jours,
que vous allez les revoir en fait, dans les lectures, vous allez en parler, donc tu vas les connaître naturellement.
-Oui c'est ça. Oui oui complètement.
-Donc c'est surtout passer le cap de la première semaine.
-Oui.
-Ca c'est le plus important.
-Je t'invite à revenir quand tu veux, et on se monte des petits sujets comme ça. Vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous aimeriez qu'on fasse avec Sébastien.
Ce dont on pourrait parler.
Mais ce mec est juste très très passionnant !
Donc profitons en !
De l'avoir à notre disposition n'est-ce pas ?!
Je recommande ton livre, "Une mémoire infaillible", qui vient de sortir en grand format.
Prenez celui-là parce qu'il y a un cahier des exercices et c'est beaucoup plus sympatique.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Et je mets un lien vers ta chaine YouTube.
Après quand on a les bons ingrédients, c'est fun d'apprendre.
-Eh oui !
-Il y a eu des discussions que j'ai eu pas mal de fois avec vous,
quand vous me dites "Oui, mais ça ça prend beaucoup plus de temps...", oui, mais en fait c'est juste pour que tu le retiennes vraiment.
[rires]
-Oui, mais il y a deux aspects. Plus de temps, ça dépend sur quelle échelle de temps on réfléchi.
-C'est ça.
Si tu réfléchis sur 5 minutes, évidemment ne fais pas toutes ces associations tu vas perdre ton temps.
Par contre si tu réfléchi sur une semaine, tu vas avoir besoin de beaucoup moins de consolidations entre et donc derrière tu gagnes déjà du temps.
-Exactement.
-En fait on ne peux pas apprendre si on ne s'amuse pas.
Même dans le travail, si on ne fait pas quelque chose qui nous plait, ça se sent du coup, les gens ils s'embêtent avec nous quoi...!
-C'est ça, sinon tu n'aimerai pas regarder mes vidéos si je m'embêterai à en faire !
C'est la même !
Merci beaucoup Seb! Allez visiter sa chaîne, pensez à regarder pour son livre, et pensez à liker à vous abonner comme d'habitude.
A très bientôt !
Ciao !
Est-ce que tu as une astuce Sébastien, pour qu'ils n'oublient pas d'appuyer sur les deux ronds là, qui sont en train d'apparaître ?
-C'est une bonne question...
-Du coup le mieux c'est qu'ils le fassent dès maintenant ?
-Oui en fait le mieux c'est de le faire de suite.
Parce que sinon ils vont oublier. Si tu ne le fais pas de suite, t'oublies.
-Et c'est un champion de mémoire qui vient de te dire ça !